good morning hank it's tuesday and would
you like a chippy buddy oh he made a
chippy buddy y'all he really did it
it's not chippy buddy it's just chip
buddy but it feels like it should be
chippy buddy it's just mayonnaise
bread you didn't have any brown sauce i
put fish sauce on it oh
god that looks awful it's just carb on
carb on carb
i need more mayonnaise what do you think
of platypuses
i think they're fantastic for me it's a
take it or leave it thing like if you
could kill the last platypus no hank of
course i would not kill him it's just
like walking slowly toward a garbage
disposal
[Laughter]
and you're like dig it or leave it it's
like the trolley problem but if you flip
the switch nothing bad happens can't
believe you're still eating it i can't
believe it's still happening there was a
hair can i identify whose it is that's
that's sarah's hank do you believe what
doesn't kill you makes you stronger um
no no i can go either way yeah sometimes
things that don't kill you make you
stronger like exercise i think it's
really
uh person-to-person situation this
situation i don't know about you but
lots of bad things have happened to
the itis heavy on the itis is going to
be the name of your memoir man that's
great hank what are your thoughts on the
upcoming f1 season
i think that i think that is a car thing
oh that's impressive i didn't think you
would know that in my head here's what i
have somewhat dependent on russian
oligarchs to be fair it relies on dirty
money from all over the world gotcha
have you ever heard of the following
names lewis hamilton i knew a guy named
lewis who was actually from a town
called hamilton he was like a biking
advocate and indeed lewis hamilton also
enjoys
transporting wheeled transportation have
you ever heard of max verstappen max
verstappen those like unlike that other
guy sounds like an f1 driver he does i'm
just saying if i heard his name max
verstappen or whatever like i'm like
yeah i guess that's not gonna have one
driver all right it's like the guy who
operated on my hand when i got my
attendant yes was named dr hand i had a
doctor an
anesthesiologist dr sleepy named dr
house oh like house md yeah yeah and
he's like
putting the anesthesia in and he says
i'm dr house or whatever and i'm like
hey do you know that there's also a uh
and i assume that's why he became an
anesthesiologist so he doesn't have that
joke over and over and over again you
know
he's like the i that's the other
anesthesiologist have you count back
from 10 i have you tell me that you've
seen a show called house no please don't
you just got it near my face on purpose
i would really wish vlogbrothers had
smell-o-vision so that everybody could
be in the boat i'm in right now they're
good chips yeah yeah no they're really
good they're from uh they're from
they're local french fries hank what are
some things that you do when you don't
feel inspired read hmm always helps
though it's hard to make myself do it
what i do is i yell at myself and i say
like you idiot get to work and that is
totally ineffective but
i've been doing it for 40 years so it's
hard it's hard to break the habit we
have to make a lot of stuff and i
regularly am like it's thursday i need
to make a video i know what i'm going to
make my video about and having gone from
the place of i think this is a disaster
and it's not going to happen to the next
day there is a video and it's good to
have it enough times that it doesn't
freak me out as much as you used to i'm
sorry that you didn't get shiny my
chippy butt you keep making the name of
it worse the name was terrible to start
and it just gets worse i'm glad that we
have a lot of british fans
who can feel
uh insulted i'm a big believer in
cultural humility but that is a bad
sandwich
hank i will continue to see you right
now i'm gonna go hang out with your son